to be all in
means that your only priority is to
always manage your state of being
if you wish to generate a different life
you need to start paying attention to
your state of consciousness
and you have to let go of circumstances
you have to become aware of your
vibration
and learn to very very consistently and
constantly choose your preferred state
of being regardless of what you see
if your state of being is 100
your chosen preference all of the time
reality will have to reflect that
physical reality is like a mirror
all it ever does is reflect you
all the time
it's constantly mirroring your state of
being your vibrational attitude
your consciousness
step back fully into the creator seat
take control of yourself and become more
deliberate in your manifestations
we are here to create things that have
never been created before
generate a presence that is of your
preference
you have to overwhelm what is appearing
as your circumstances
with your chosen vibratory presence
you have to manifest and generate the
experience that you want consciously
this is actually one of the most
powerful keys to becoming conscious
again of the fact that you are god that
you are the creator
it's to actually practice inundating and
overwhelming your reality with your
chosen presence your chosen frequency
then you will really fall in love with
your reality with your creation
you will start to become one with it
what i'm talking about is a really high
finely tuned intentional state of love
light that can have any shape
choose one of the facets of that high
vibrational love light of the one
infinite creator
tap into it and dominate your reality
with it
this is your creation it's not your
reception
you are never receiving anything ever
you're only ever giving life to creation
it is a mechanical impossibility to
experience someone else's energy
it's always your version of them
you need to counter what you've been
doing for decades which is
i'm over here
and you're over there
ultimately that is the only love there
is
the one wanting to know itself
existence doesn't desire me
is the feeling of unworthiness
all of this creation is really the one
looking at itself
you are that one that wants to know
itself
and so you are generating this reality
this is just one of your many realities
you are everywhere all at once
moving at infinite speeds while
remaining absolutely still
consciousness is always here every
experience you have meets inside of
consciousness inside of you
you can never change you
you can never leave you
you
are inescapable
you as consciousness you as awareness
you as that witnessing principle
you as that ever-present being are
inescapable
your vibrational attitude is how you
view yourself in any given moment
how you view yourself determines the way
you experience life
it determines your state of being
your vibrational attitude is what you
are constantly emitting
the energy or frequency of your being
the state of your consciousness
you are choosing your images out of a
field of infinite parallel
probable realities
realize that your consciousness has the
ability to change the picture
to shift into a parallel reality
intentionally
the more awareness you bring into your
experience
the more you can change your thoughts
your consciousness your attention your
vibratory state
what is the next most exciting uplifting
empowering thing to generate
for myself and for the rest of myself
the rest of my creation
you have to enter willingly into your
creator seat
step into the vibratory state where you
know that you are responsible for the
reflections you see
what you see is what you are
what you choose
is what you see
what you feel is what you create
what you see is a reflection of what you
are being
you have to become aware of your
vibration and learn to very very
consistently
choose your preferred state of being
regardless of what you see
regardless of how things appear do not
flinch
you can still communicate with others
and accept the conventional appearance
of reality
but internally subjectively your state
of being is 100 percent your chosen
preference all of the time
using your state of being
overpower your experience of what is
with only your preference
while maintaining complete respect for
the seeming existence of other people's
free will
i want to inspire you to constantly
desire to stay alert and be aware of
what you are sending out
until you reach a super satisfactory
state where your life is no longer
generated randomly but consciously
to be all in
means that it is your only priority to
determine and direct your own state of
being at all times
the resonance is what it's about the
frequency
the state of being is what you really
want
you want the feeling of it you want the
beingness of it
you can't really know what that's like
you can't really know how to respond or
interact from that space
you can't really recognize that
integrity
until you start actually experiencing it
you can only experience what it's like
when you expand beyond your bubble
beyond your biases beyond your
preferences and you remember your true
preference
place everything you desire in your past
a little while ago
as if it already happened
and feel what that was like
to be in the future
generates more presence than to be in
the present
which is based on the past
there's nothing more beautiful than to
be in a state of pure desire without
doubt
knowing that you are connected to all
that is
knowing that you are infinitely powerful
and infinitely abundant
that state itself becomes your home
that state itself becomes your freedom
your liberation
your source of power and well-being
it becomes your ability to manifest the
things truly relevant for you quickly
rapidly often as if magically so
that state itself is super accelerated
living